Oh
hello everyone and we're glad you've
joined us for this live webinar
continuous improvement in sample
management presented by beloved J Patel
and Zachary coke ler of Brooks Life
Sciences I am Christina LaFave Oakland
I'll be moderating the session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth and is sponsored by Brooks
life sciences for more information on
our sponsor please visit Brookes life
sciences comm now before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them in the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab down at the top right of
your presentation window or report your
problem by using the ask a question box
this presentation is educational and
best offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
lastly at the end of this presentation
you will research receive a survey which
we kindly ask you to complete your
answers and suggestions will help
improve our webinar program and are
greatly appreciated
I now present today's speakers bill
Lovett director bio bank operations and
continuous improvement J Patel
continuous improvement specialist and
Zachary cochlear continuous improvement
specialist all of Brookes life sciences
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen gentlemen you may now
begin your presentation
thanks Christy hi I'm Zach Kobler I am
currently a part of the continuous
improvement team here at Brookes life
sciences as a continuous improvement
specialist I recently graduated from
Purdue University with the Bachelors of
Science in industrial engineering and a
minor in organizational leadership and
supervision while at Purdue I gained a
passion for lean methodology and I
earned my green belt Six Sigma
certification along with my 30 hour OSHA
certification after I graduated I was
hired on as an Operations intern at
Brookes life sciences when in which I
worked very closely with Jay and Bill
right now I am currently a continuous
improvement specialist underneath bill
excellent thanks Zack so I'm beloved
I've been with Brookes Life Sciences for
about three years now I have
responsibility for the Indianapolis 500
yen D biobank and it's the largest of
Brookes life sciences bio banks that we
have we have global vie banks all over
the world but this is the very largest
one I'm an engineer by degree an
electrical engineering degree from
Vanderbilt University I've been working
for a very long time 20 plus years of
that experience has been in leadership
and continuously using and having
success with executing continuous
improvement type projects so bringing a
wealth of experience to the organization
and work very closely to mentor both
Zack and Jay who can take it off next
often thanks bill the bill mention I am
on the continuous improvement team at
Brix life sciences wall working very
closely with both Bo and Zack I'm Heidi
y alumnus with a degree in health
services management and a minor in
policy studies I've been with the
organization for about two years now and
been practicing lean for three years and
I'm very excited to share off my
experiences with you all today
excellent so one of the things we wanted
to start off with was you know what does
Brooks life science is all about and
we're really all about the sample so as
we you know look at this particular
slide and you see the life cycle of a
sample throughout that you know
customers have it you plan how you're
going to get it you collect it
transportation of it to wherever you
want to store it and that's really when
our biobank comes into play we process
that sample into storage know exactly
where it's at we make sure that we're
protecting it keeping it at the right
temperature stored with the right types
of materials etc and then we pride
ourselves on being able to retrieve
those samples very quickly and provide
them back to the customer if they need
them for something send them to a third
party location to be tested or in a lot
of cases just to get them disposed of
and provide certificates that they have
been disposed of but as we look at this
whole slide and you you would have seen
this if you've done anything else with
Brooks this is really what all of Brooks
life sciences is about but today we're
going to really focus on those three
areas which we you know we say is our
bio Bank and most specifically we're
going to be talking about how we've
utilized continuous improvement to
improve how we do process protect and
retrieve our customer sample so J with
that loan should kick us off sure thanks
Bill so while we look into the
principles of lean methodology and how
it applies in bio bank and we look
forward to your questions at the end of
this presentation again thank you very
much for joining us today and your
willingness to learn about continuous
improvement and sample management so
let's get started at its core lean is
all about identifying and eliminating
waste now we see waste everywhere
whether you're shopping at a local
grocery store or registering a sample
inside a bio bank and it's very normal
for people to get used to or accept the
status quo so we want to
UNC and how these tools can help you
overcome these tendencies
and with that being said Zach why don't
you take this topic long a little bit
further sure thanks Jay
so on the left side you see Value Added
so steps within your process could be
value-added these steps add something to
your product or your service which the
customer is willing to pay for so value
added steps adds value to the customer
and you gain most of your expending
company resources from doing so the
opposite so on the right side is
non-value-added these steps include
waste however just because it's a not
vat is a non value-added process steps
it doesn't mean it's a bad thing
often we must perform perform these
steps due to regulatory or compliance
reasons for example here at Brooks we
must have radio a back of radioactive
backup storage units these radioactive
backup storage units are taking
resources in order to be operational
however we have to do so in order to be
compliant you want to minimize these
steps as much as possible now pure waste
is no value or no required it's no
value-added and it's not required so
this pretty much means that resources
have been extended some expended delays
have occurred and customers are not
willing to pay this usually occurs when
you have under utilization of the
workforce or if you have unnecessary
handoffs
these steps you want to completely
eliminate from your processes now that
you understand the different categories
of waste Jay will explain how to
identify the types of waste thanks Zach
so let's get into it I know everyone on
the phones thinking how right how can
you identify waste in your everyday
processes so when we talk about the 7
wastes of lean they'll put some
structure to this and help you
understand the pure waste that Zach just
described within your processes
so next we'll take a deep dive into each
of the 7 wastes and we'll all provide
some examples in bio bank settings and
try and relate those back to everyone on
the phone and some of the written or bio
bank bliss processes so hopefully you
find this beneficial and with that being
said why don't we let bill kicks off
well Before we jump into the details
let's have a little fun so want to
introduce you to the most important
person that's behind this whole lean
methodology named Tim Wood now he's not
really a person he's just a way to
remember the titles of the different
types of waste in the being an acronym
so transportation for the Tim and Tim
wood etc so just keep that in the back
your mind in a way to remember those
ones and now we're going to step through
each of those particular things so the a
conch-shell is about the waste of
transportation sure thanks Bill waste of
transportation is defined as unnecessary
movement of people and materials between
processes so often I'm an example of
this would be moving sample shipments
between building or receiving shipments
at one building while the processing is
at another and often for inventory
stocking locations can also cause a
waste in transportation and Jay will
talk a little bit about a waste in
inventory sure thanks Zach waste of
inventory is basically everything raw
material everything that work that's
work in progress and even the finish
goods that aren't really adding any
value to to you or your customer so in
other words holding inventory whether
that's material or information more than
required so I'll give you an example the
files and documents that we have to wait
to be processed is a good example of the
waste of inventory now whether you over
order your consumables to support the
sample
management operations or scheduling
issues from the suppliers there are all
great examples the waste of inventory
now bill want to walk us through the
waste of motion yeah so when we speak
about motion we're really speaking about
the movement of people parts for
machines within a process I'm going to
stop there for a second to point out
that word within and then in comparison
to the top of this slide where Zack was
talking about transportation and he
talked about between so it really is the
key difference between transportation
waste and motion waste is whether it's
between processes or places and what or
whether it's within the process that
you're doing so if you think about the
waste of motion inside of a you know bio
bank it's walking throughout the
facility it is reaching to get materials
moving your hands around more than they
need to be readjusting scanners things
of this nature but it can also be things
like searching for files so as anybody
you know when you go to do your tax's
ever spend a little bit of unnecessary
time trying to find those documents that
you got throughout the year I know I
sure have so that's the kind of things
that happen and those happen in the bio
bank as well if you have materials that
you file away but you don't have a great
filing system you can take more time
than necessary moving around motion
searching for things looking for things
that also happens with inadequate layout
of a workstation or not having supplies
at your fingertips having to you know
walk across a building or you know with
a bio bank and being in a area being all
gound it up if you're if your materials
are sitting in the office space you've
got a completely be gone and wash up and
go grab your stuff and come back and all
of that would be considered excess
motion or waste that's due to those
motions so with that we'll move on to
the next slide and Zack you'll pick up
with the next waste
so the next wave is waiting nobody likes
to wait neither do the employees so
anytime that a technician is waiting to
be assigned a job or waiting on
equipment maintenance to be completed
you are wasting time and resources so in
order to eliminate this waiting time
it's best to create a single piece flow
or a more leveled workload but being
careful not to over produce which is our
next waste yep and speaking speaking of
overproduction you know what kind of
things would be overproduction for you
know our kind of environments and you
know one of those would be printing
documents out way in advance and you
print those out and then you're having
to then that leads to other ways right
it's interesting how these things kind
of interact with one another so if you
over produce stuff you're doing stuff
too far in advance you have the risk of
losing it that gets misplaced more time
being spent or like we wrote up here on
the board
you know printing more labels than you
need means you're going to throw labels
away so you've not only wasted the time
it took to print the label but you
wasted the actual resource of the label
as well and ink and all the rest of it
so those are the things that happen when
you choose to over produce
and last not lastly but next we will
have Jay talk about the active
over-processing
sure thanks well and I think the term
itself gives itself up right the
definition it just being that you're
doing more than what's required to meet
the clients expectations so this could
be you know too many approvals required
to add a new project into your system
any additional quality control checks
and your bio banking practices you know
that would require duplication of
efforts and you know this one might
actually hit the home for those in this
arena when you're autoclaving when
you're in generating examples when
autoclave can be sufficient those are
all good examples of all practicing the
waste of over processing so now Zack why
don't you go over the last wastes thanks
Jay so do it right the first time that's
a phrase that I'm sure most of you have
heard before so defects they cause a
waste and time a waste and resources and
a waste and effort to try to create or
correct the failure some of these
examples would be retrieving the wrong
sample or a data inaccuracy it's
important to focus on these common
errors and redesign the process to
reduce the number of defects definitely
target those pain points so now I'll
pass it off to bill to discuss how our
business uses the knowledge of waste to
improve the organization's layout yeah
thanks Zack so you know very interesting
when I started my leadership role here
at Brookes life sciences in the bio Bank
which was late 2016 one of the first
things that I had as a challenge was how
do I increase the amount of processing
and retrieval capacity that the
organization had without increasing our
physical space so we have a sample admin
administration area which has some walls
around it and doors and was really asked
you need to still do that work inside of
that square footage so we're growing as
an organization and growing at a free
ass clip and therefore need to be able
to drive that extra capacity so that
really started off with observing
observe what people are doing observe
the process one of the tools that you
can use is call this via t diagram this
parity diagram is really nothing more
than just on a piece of paper which is
has a picture of your layout follow
follow the process walk the actual
process and draw on the paper what you
would the operator is actually doing and
boy did we have a pile of spaghetti
because then great to have some meats
and meatballs with that but you know
it's not unusual it is what usually
everybody finds whenever you walk really
any processes you know J it said in the
very beginning even if it's going to the
grocery store that makes how many times
did you like walk down that center aisle
instead of the one time that you should
have gotten everything on your lips from
that aisle especially if the new store
you're walking all over that crazy store
so you know what we found was a lot lots
of waste from that lots of waste of
motion associated with that but that's
not all we found because we really
started to look at what was going on we
had a situation in which people were
having to walk into the area log into a
computer at their workstation get into
our system that we use here for our
biobank get their work assignment
understand the location of where they're
going to pick up their materials and you
know know what they need to do then they
would log out of that computer they
would walk outside to an area where we
had some carts and carts had these
containers on them with that we'll call
from here on in our discussion whips
work-in-progress has the bin itself that
we're talking about not the actual work
when we're saying whips through this
discussion and an interesting thing was
is that you know they went out there and
got that they logged back into that
computer so that they were doing
real-time moves of their material then
we come back into the area now they have
to offload it so identified which is a
waste
and a concern so we didn't really talk
about the floor and that's one that I'll
often would be called that eighth waste
and that's the eighth eighth waste is
having kind of safety concerns and the
loss that you can have from the business
of having somebody get hurt
so we also found that by picked the
people were picking up these whips and
often these whips were quite heavy and
they were having to twist and put it on
a stand and then when they were done
with their work they were having do that
again so we really you know were able to
through utilizing that tool the speedy
diagram and by observing and by really
thinking about Tim Wood and use it
taking Tim woods advice and looking at
all the different types of ways we were
able to increase our workstation
capacity in that space by 25% and as
exact at the same time simultaneously we
reduced excess motion we reduced over
processing and we eliminated a lot of
waiting that was going on
so probably the biggest thing that we
did was eliminate that safety concern
and really truly give our workers a
better work environment so with that
with that discussion I'm going to turn
it over to Zach which took on our kind
of next journey that we did once we had
that layout and we had the capacity we
needed we wanted to continue to improve
that work environment for our employees
does that going to talk about the
project that you worked on next sure
so the 5s is often referred to as
successes it's a philosophy and this
philosophy focuses on organizing and
managing the workplace by eliminating
the seven types of waste that we've been
talking about today and we eliminate
these wastes while also improving
quality improving safety and performance
of the technician so the primary five SS
goes as follows can read it on the
screen but it's sort set an order shine
standardize sustain and then the success
I'll talk about later which is safety
but this first step is sorting so when
you are sorting you're identified
identifying all of the items in the work
area that is necessary employees are
supposed to distinguish whether or not
that items needed at Brooks we have
something called the red tag table it's
a great tool to use to separate valuable
equipment and non valuable equipment or
maybe equipment that's not necessarily
being used at this time and by
scheduling periodic audits of this table
we're able to put items back that we
know that the technicians need and we
just need to find a better home for or
we just dispose or recycle of items that
we no longer need but after you've
essentially sorted out this unnecessary
tooling you must set an order a standard
consistent way to store and retrieve
necessary materials so with each item
being returned to the workplace
immediately after use you're pretty much
successfully minimizing time spent
searching for tools and equipment a way
we do this at Brooks is by color line
marking certain processes or signage for
equipment and supplying technicians with
a shadow board and and what's what's
very important to learn is that you have
to clean the area or as we say shine
which is that next step there
and it's critical it's absolutely
critical for sustaining the 5s effort
because workers are cleaning their area
on a daily basis equipment malfunctions
and other issues can be easily
identified this will reduce wait times
for equipment malfunction and other and
other sorts of issues so standardization
can really only occur after the three
other asses so the short the satin the
shine and to standardize you're creating
that set standard of responsibilities
that the operator must follow daily of
course this must be periodically
evaluated and to ensure that the
individual is actually doing their job
we do this here at Brooks by an end of
review sheet the technician would look
on the sheet at the end of the day and
know exact
what to do with each technician at the
end of the day doing such said set
standard process we know when something
goes wrong
and we know how to fix it so like I said
earlier 5s only works if it's sustained
and has everybody on it so by sustaining
5s in the workplace you're assigning
employees a time to complete the task
you're also giving them a clean and
comfortable work environment to be at
something that they want to come in some
every single day creating that reward
system may be having a reward system for
those who are supporting the 5s
initiative it always works so it really
is a monkey-see monkey-do situation and
what I mean by that is upper level
management participate inside the 5s
activities embrace this philosophy and
your employees will follow
lastly Brooks we consider safety as the
success that's something and what still
mentioned earlier safety concerns can
cause weight and often these wastes come
in many different forms they come in
delays they come in damaged or even
worse injuries to your employee so it's
very important that you have six you
have the 6s and that you are following
the regulations and regulatory standards
so not only can you eliminate waste
within the work environment but you can
eliminate waste within your
organization's core operational process
and Jay will speak on that now thanks
Zach
as eck mentioned minimizing waste from
the core ops processes I think that this
project really ties that concept in and
so we kicked off the defrag project
earlier this year the idea that we had
was to assess the capacity of our bio
bank and really understand and eliminate
the inefficiencies that are caused by
inadequate storage of samples right
within our storage boxes so I'll walk
you through the process as you can see
on top of your
green technician goes inside a freezer
to retrieve the samples that are ordered
by the client whether she ship the
samples back to them do extra processing
where the reason might be leaving empty
spots within that tray or the storage
box and it goes back inside the freezer
for how long
you never know could be days weeks or
years so now that you have a little bit
of background into this process this
project was aimed to minimize the under
utilization of the storage boxes and
really eliminate the inefficiencies
associated with the retrieval process as
well so we did a lot of data analysis
initially to understand how full our
storage boxes are and you know
understood the limitations that were in
place especially the size of the samples
and the type of material to stay within
the boundaries in our analysis really as
you can see it in the Pareto chart in
the middle there
it showed that with significant control
over over the backfilling process and it
was effective but as you can see in the
tail she still had low opportunity there
to improve so as we tie this whole
project into the seven waste that we
discussed earlier the first one that
really comes to mind is the waste of
overproduction as we're creating you
know the new storage boxes and even the
old boxes were under under-filled the
second one is the width motion that bill
had went over earlier that we began to
add new freezers which led us to a
bigger footprint for of the of the floor
and for storage causing excessive
movement of people equipment as well as
the material and both of which also
point to the third way so outline now is
the waste of inventory as we started to
have excessive amount of storage boxes
and new freezers were put into service
that were adding zero to no value to
process itself so we started noticing a
few of the benefits as part of this
project
this effort really allowed us to delay
the purchase of the new storage boxes in
the capital equipment such as ultra low
temperature freezers we eliminated the
additional freezer maintenance those
done by our facilities team locally and
we were also able to perform a quality
control check on the freezers that had
very low access so speaking of the
storage boxes we have a very specific
type of storage and we had identified
that were defect grace rate was higher
than other sample types so I'll let Zach
get in the details of this improvement
project right so thanks Jay as mentioned
earlier defects can cause waste by
reprocessing Andry correcting that
failure so you can combat this type of
waste by holding something that we call
is a a Kaizen event this Kaizen event is
made up of a cross-functional team of
operation of operators technicians
managers and you gather the perspective
you map the existing process you discuss
improvements and pain points that you
may have within that process and then
you gain buy-in from all of the
department that's where the success will
lead you in our case we held the Kaizen
event over a fly box handling so like I
said we mapped our current process or
handling process and we found pain
points we also reviewed any documented
errors that we we had over slide
handling issues and the team came up
with a few areas of improvement some of
these improvements were space concerns
eliminating large sub shelves managing
down stacking so we brainstormed and
tested solution and so what you see on
the screen here are some of the
solutions that we came came up with so
that first solution is the physical and
virtual grid system the physical grid
system that you see there on the left
and the right holds different types of
slide boxes so so on the left is a 1 by
25 slide box holder
the other one is a 1 by 100 now the
physical grid system allows for sample
integrity quick retrieval and it
prevents overfilled bins now the virtual
grid system allows us to have capacity
visibility without even physically
checking to see if there's space or not
space now we've also eliminated the
large sub sub shells and reduce that
size of the bin and came out with a
smile and started using smaller bins
these smaller bins are less heavy and
smaller in size once again this is an
ergonomic to the technician and it frees
up other storage opportunities you see
there on the depth of the bottom left
that we have a cart this is a walking
cart and it encourages proper down
stacking which will lead us to the sub
shelf retrieval layout as I also like to
follow the slide handling area this
slide handling area is a dedicated
location that supports an AIDS
retrievals of storage of slide boxes it
perfectly fits their small bins and
assists with the general workflow while
requiring little to no down stacking
which was once again one of those major
pain points lastly being prepared for
the unexpected you're picking you're
taking the initiative so this means
having any adequate containments is a
must when dealing with non-conformities
or found defects so in conclusion the
Kaizen teams the Kaizen team did a great
job and are in the efforts focused on
mitigating slide handling defects
reducing that waste in motion and
overall decreasing weight time so I'll
now have bill close this out for today
excellent thanks Zack great example one
of the things that I was thinking right
as you started and I know I did as I've
moved from industry to industry it's
always if I'm not a traditional
manufacturing environment how's this
lean thing going to work and
you know I hope that the explanation of
the theory are examples of how those
different principles do work within a
biorepository as well as the examples of
what we did to improve our operation put
you in a position that you want to go
through your rolodex for those of you
still have one and your cell phone for
most today but get you know get Tim
woods number up give him a call take his
advice and identify the wastes that are
going on within your your business then
yank out that toolkit you got a toolkit
of the knowledge of value add and non
value add your spaghetti diagrams your
process mapping 5s utilization of Kaizen
and really at the end of the day look
look everywhere that you can to reduce
the waste you know really focusing on
minimizing things that are required but
make those things as easy as possible if
they're not adding value to your
customer and try to truly eliminate
those things are pure waste and you know
we really hope that this helps you be in
a position to be able to improve your
your operation to you know hit whatever
goal it is that you're trying to hit but
maintain the quality and safety of your
environment while you're doing it thank
you very much and I look forward to your
questions
thank you gentlemen for your
presentation so let's get started with
our QA now just a quick reminder to our
audience on how to submit questions just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and as a
reminder any questions we are not able
to get to today bill J and Shaq will be
answering them via email so don't worry
if we don't get to your question right
away all right so our first question how
do you believe lean methodology and
continuous improvement will affect your
company three to five years down the
road
thanks Chrissy this is Jay Patel I can
answer that question I think that three
to five years down the road you expect
that you know we accelerate our
improvements as by then we have built
the infrastructure that allows changes
at a faster pace and a workforce that
accepts those changes as well and I
guess another piece of that is agility
and through continuous improvement of
our processes will improve the agility
to react to the new opportunities and
changes in the marketplace more readily
thanks Jay now will you cover system to
track the material yeah this is Bill
Lovett so here at Brooks Life Sciences
we do have a company proprietary
inventory management system which was
specifically designed with sample
management and specifically biological
sample management as it's a core tenant
so now what have you found unique about
applying these manufacturing principles
in a bio bank environment yeah it's kind
of an interesting one because although
you know it is unique I personally have
worked in a number of different
industries some of which were
specifically manufacturing which was
what these these tools and things are
specifically aimed at but as I've worked
in different service industries with
this being one of delivering a you know
bio bank services to our customers it
it's even though there is uniqueness you
can always go back to you know slides 8
& 9 went through each of the different
ways and gave the classical description
but then we gave an example or two of
what worked within the bio Bank it the
bottom line is that the general
principles have always applied and we've
not really had issues in doing so thanks
again bill and out have you had any
pushback from the workforce and how have
you handled that so that's a great
question to answer that is yeah we've
encountered pushback and really change
is hard for anyone so you will encounter
employees who challenge ideas or have a
difficult time adjusting to these new
implementation a way that we handle this
at Brookes life sciences is we set clear
expectations before implementing the
change and we also involve the employees
in the development of that solution so
gaining their support gaining their
buy-in you will often be able to use a
quote that's let's remember these were
the solutions we agreed on or these were
the goals that we agreed on you want to
be using that to leverage yourself and
lastly you want to get to know your
employee so you understand what
motivates them and motivation is key in
the workplace so you do not always need
to motivate your employees with money
you can
enter you can motivate these employees
by possibly creating a flexible schedule
for them or giving extra breaks or maybe
even providing a quieter office
everybody has their own motivation to
get things done that's a great question
yeah this is beloved and with that I
just like to thank everybody for you
know listening in today and listening to
our journey as we've been using
continuous improvement to benefit our
bio Bank and ultimately for those that
are customers on the on the line to us
the better our service to you as
customers and you know lastly this
continuous improvement it is a journey
so we look forward to continuing to move
forward utilizing lean over the next few
years and extending to more advanced
methods of continuous improvement as we
improve upon our capability within our
group so thank you very much everybody
and hope you have a great day thank you
Bell and thank you Jay and Zack for your
time today and for your excellent
presentation I'd also like to thank
labyrinth and our sponsor Brooks life
sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast now before we go I
also want to thank all of you for
joining us today and for your great
questions
as a reminder those questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration now a survey will
pop up on your screen and your
participation is greatly appreciated
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinth will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and we
thanks for you for joining us have a
great day
you